an Idaho family is fighting the
government in court after a federal
worker mistakenly placed a cyanide trap
near the family's home mark and Teresa
Mane's Mansfield are suing for more than
one hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in damages they say the Trapp injured
their son and killed their dog
government lawyers say the family is to
blame for any damages Anna Werner is
here with their response and a good
morning and good morning John Canyon
Mansfield activated a cyanide trap known
as an m40 for its device the US
Department of Agriculture uses to kill
predatory animals like coyotes and
according to the family no one with the
government told them the poisonous
device was near their backyard every
parent wants their child to be able to
go outside behind their house walk their
dog without feeling like they're in
danger
Teresa Mansfield says her son still
suffers from headaches more than a year
after the incident that she says injured
him and killed their pet Canyon
Mansfield was playing with his dog Casey
behind their home in March 2017 when
Canyon saw what he describes as a
sprinkler like pipe sticking out of the
ground the teen described what happened
to the Idaho State Journal just days
later so I've been down I touch in I
hear a pop and then Isis and then so
that's the gas coming up and like it was
orange powder Canyon says he knew the
situation was dangerous and he tried to
call Casey to him but the dog wasn't
getting up I saw the this red froth
coming from his mouth and like his eyes
turning glassy and it was like having a
seizure
the device was an m40 for cyanide trap
designed to protect livestock from
predators according to court documents
the device was about 300 yards behind
the Mansfield's property on federally
managed land an agriculture department
worker acknowledged placing the cyanide
trap and The Associated Press reports
the government decided to stop using the
traps on federal lands in Idaho months
earlier but in court documents filed on
Monday the government rejected the
Mansfield's claims and asked for their
lawsuit to be dismissed claiming the
family's negligence led to Casey's death
and canyons injuries
but Mansfield claims the state of Idaho
found federal wildlife services at fault
I find it crazy that the state of Idaho
find wildlife service's $6,000 for
negligence with our case but yet the US
government is saying it's our fault we
reached out to the Justice Department
the US Bureau of Land Management and the
Department of Agriculture will all
decline to comment Nora I've never heard
of a cyanide trap in 44 I've never heard
of that they actually use these efforts
to control what they consider to be you
know problem animals or like cattle
ranchers out there but there's a lot of
dispute over what kind of animals
they're killing and whether they really
need to kill them and then of course you
have these incidents this is not the
only one where a pet or a human came
across them you think they should at
least let residents know about what
these are right that's what the family
is saying like hey it's right behind our
house right for a government that
believes in giving power to the states
the argument from the state that the
government is at fault seems to be a
pretty powerful piece of information in
the case right Anna thank you